inciso se sea fx una solución particular
a la ecuación diferencial tabla con la
condición inicial
efe de 2 igual a 3 la función f tiene un
máximo relativo un mínimo relativo a
ninguno de los dos en x igualados
justifica tu respuesta bueno antes de
pensar si tiene un mínimo relativo o un
máximo relativo vamos a pensar en la
derivada en ese punto y bueno si la
derivada es 0 o no está definida
entonces va a ser un muy buen candidato
para hacer un mínimo relativo o un
máximo relativo pero si no es 0 o está
definida entonces inmediatamente va a
ser ninguno de los dos entonces vamos a
evaluar la derivada en este punto y
recuerda si es cero entonces vamos a
evaluar el signo de la segunda derivada
para saber si es un máximo relativo o un
mínimo relativo así que vamos a pensar
un poco esto y bueno nosotros queremos
evaluar f prima de 2 queremos saber
cuánto valen f
de dos y para eso vamos a recordar
primero cuánto valían efedrina de equis
y bueno efe prima de x es lo mismo que
la derivada del yen con respecto a x
verdad con respecto a x y es justo lo
que veíamos en el vídeo anterior porque
acá arriba dice que la derivada de llegó
respecto a x es 2x - james 2x menos
james y es lo que nos decía el problema
entonces siempre prima de x es 2x menos
bien cuanto es entre prima de 2 bueno
pues esto va a ser lo mismo que 2 que
multiplica a x x vale 2 - bien pero
cuánto vale bien cuando x vale 2 bueno
eso nos lo dicen justo aquí cuando x
vale 2 cuando x vale 2 quien toma el
valor de 3 porque recuerda y es igual a
fx entonces cuando x vale 2 llévale 3 y
aquí me quedaría 2 x 2 menos tres lo
cual es exactamente lo mismo
3 lo cual es una de lujo ahora observa
la derivada evaluada en 2 no es 0 es 1
entonces este punto de aquí esté aquí en
definitiva no será un máximo y será un
mínimo entonces por lo tanto podemos
decir que como
efe prima de dos es distinto de cero
entonces entonces la función
efe
no tiene no tiene
ni un máximo
relativo y un máximo relativo de la
digo ni un mínimo relativo ni
mínimo
relativo
en donde el x igual a 2 en x igual a 2 y
ya con esto finalizamos este inciso
ok entonces este es el inciso sean bajos
al inciso del índice
encuentra los valores de las constantes
m y ver para qué igual
mx más bien sea una solución de la
ecuación diferencial ok qué te parece si
antes de pensar para que m ítem se
cumple que esta recta sea la solución de
una ecuación diferencial primero
escribimos abajo todo lo que ya sabemos
lo primero que sabemos es que bueno la
derivada de bien esto con respecto a x
eso nos lo dan es lo mismo que dos x
menos 10 muy bien y también habíamos
sacado que la segunda derivada de jeff
esto con respecto a x ambas veces es lo
mismo que 2 - la derivada de james con
respecto a x fue justo lo que vimos en
la parte de de este problema y bueno
también vimos que esta misma segunda
derivada esta segunda derivada también
la podemos escribir en términos de x
y también la podemos escribir como dos
menos dos equis más y eso también lo
obtuvimos en la parte de este problema
recuerda está justo por aquí y es que
aquí escribimos la segunda derivada en
términos de x de james como 2 - 2x
martín muy bien creo que hasta aquí es
todo lo que sabemos hasta ahorita
inclusive antes de pensar que había una
solución de la forma que es igual a mx
más ver así que qué te parece si ahora
empezamos con esto con que james es
igual a mx más vea si empezamos justo
con esto qué va a pasar si te digamos
qué pasa si derivamos esta función que
tengo aquí cuál es la derivada de james
con respecto a x bueno pues esto va a
ser lo mismo que la derivada de mx
es lo mismo que m y la derivada de b
bueno es una constante entonces su
derivada va a ser cero
y esto tiene todo el sentido porque la
tasa de cambio de con respecto a x en
una recta es justo la pendiente entonces
es todo lo que sabemos incluso podemos
ir más lejos y no se tomar la segunda
derivada de james con respecto a x ambas
veces la segunda derivada del llegó
respecto a x va a ser buena la derivada
de una constante es 0 así que me
quedaría igual a 0 y eso es cierto
porque la segunda derivada de una
función lineal siempre es cero así que
bueno esto es muy interesante porque es
toda la información que tenemos esto era
lo que nos daba el problema de una
manera inicial y estos dos los obtuvimos
en los ejercicios anteriores y aquí
bueno tengo a la recta y lo único que
hice fue derivar la una vez y dos veces
entonces dado todo esto como podemos
averiguar cuánto vale m y cuánto vale b
bueno lo primero que se me ocurre es que
si decimos que m
igual a la primera derivada de x
entonces va a ser 2x menos james y bueno
no creo que por aquí no sale nada
no podríamos obtener nada porque no
sabemos el valor de m entonces no sé
estoy casi seguro que este ejercicio
debe tener algún truco escondido veamos
o mira yo sé que la segunda derivada
tiene que ser igual a cero entonces
podemos usar eso justo aquí esta de aquí
vale cero para esta solución particular
y bueno también para este caso sabemos
que la derivada de llegó al respecto a x
es la pendiente así que esto es la
pendiente y del ojo ya está súper porque
ya tenemos la información necesaria para
resolver para m
ahora tenemos que 0 0 es igual a 2 - m
es justo lo que me dice esta ecuación de
aquí 0 porque sabemos que la segunda
derivada de ye gon respecto a x es 0
para una ecuación lineal
sabemos que la derivada de ella con
respecto a x en una ecuación lineal es m
entonces si de aquí sumo m de ambos
lados me va a quedar que m es igual a 2
y esto está de lujo porque nos va a
ayudar bastante a poder obtener la
solución de este problema ya sabemos m
ahora nos falta b bueno pues ahora
podemos usar esta m igualados justo aquí
aquí se me ocurre usarla si en lugar de
esto pongo que esto es m pero m es igual
a 2 en este caso entonces me quedaría
que 2 es igual a 2x
-10 y ya está ya de aquí podemos obtener
abrir porque si resolvemos esto para
ayer bueno lo que se me ocurre es sumar
que de ambos lados y restar dos de ambos
lados me va a quedar que es igual a 2 x
menos 2 - 2 y ya está porque aquí puedes
ver que esta es mi pendiente ni
pendiente y este de aquí este de aquí va
a ser ven me ve justo lo que estábamos
buscando al final este ejercicio es un
poco tramposo siempre que tengas que
hacer algo como este ejercicio es decir
algo que no te brinque inmediatamente
porque no sea tan obvio como ven en este
caso en un principio no tenía una idea
clara de cómo resolver el problema pero
lo que te aconsejo y observa lo primero
que hice fue escribir acá abajo todo lo
que sabía y después escribí justo acá lo
que me daba el problema
esta debe de ser una solución entonces
déjame ver si de alguna forma puede
obtener a m ya ve y observa que de esto
no usted en el problema se observa esta
está bueno no lo sé pero esto si lo usen
estos y lo usen esto sí lo hacen y esto
también lo usen entonces observa este
fue un pequeño rompecabezas donde tuve
que escribir todo lo que ya sabía la
información que nos dieron y tuve que
encontrar la solución con base en ello
sólo así pudo obtener a m en llave y
ahora todo es bastante claro que esta va
a ser la solución porque observa si
regresamos por ejemplo acá a nuestro
campo dependientes que teníamos en un
principio a este que tengo aquí y ahora
me tomo la recta y es igual a 2 x menos
2 como se va a ver bueno
aquí tengo el punto 10 coma menos 2 y
entonces ésta
se va a ver más o menos así déjame
dibujarla se va a ver más o menos más o
menos así si nos fijamos en algunos de
estos puntos de esta recta en este de
aquí en este de aquí o en
este de aquí observa que todos tienen la
misma pendiente igual a 2 por ejemplo
éste el punto 2 2 me quedarían dos por
dos menos dos lo cual es dos por ejemplo
éste otro el punto x igual a uno ya
igual a cero me quedaría 2 x 1 - 0 lo
cual también es 2 y este punto por acá x
igual a cero y de igual a menos 2 me
quedaría 2 x 0 se va y después menos
menos dos lo cual también es 2 y si
observas ahora es bastante claro pues
todas las pendientes alrededor están
cambiando pero esta es una solución
lineal a nuestra ecuación diferencial
original cualquiera de estos puntos
tiene la misma pendiente que va a ser
igual a 2 súper